we're told that administrators at a
school are considering a policy change
they survey a group of students staff
members and parents about whether or not
they agree with the new policy
the following mosaic plot summarizes
their results
which of the following statements can we
justify from the mosaic plot
so pause this video and try to figure
this out on your own pick which of these
statements can be justified and there
could be more than one
based on this mosaic plot
all right now let's work through this
together so before i even look at the
choices let me see if i can interpret
this
so this mosaic plot what it does above
and beyond a segmented bar chart
is it gives us the width that shows us
how many
for example students versus staff versus
parents were sampled
or surveyed and it looks like more than
half
of the people surveyed were students and
then staff and parents seem similar
in terms of who is agreeing with the
policy so that's that light blue color
it seems like students are not that not
very likely to agree with the policy
looks like staff
is very likely to agree with the policy
that the bulk of staff is agreeing with
it
and parents are kind of on both sides
so let's see which of these statements
are consistent with what we just looked
at
parents were the least likely to agree
with the new policy
no that's not true the least likely to
agree with the new policy
that students right over here they were
definitely the least likely the lowest
percentage of students
are agreeing with the policy so i don't
like that
choice more than half of the total
responses came from students
and that does look like the case because
if you view this entire width as the
total responses
it looks like the student width right
over here that is more
than half of it it looks like it's about
50 something percent or even 60 percent
so i like this choice right over here
and then last but not least there were
more total
no responses from students than from
staff
and parents combined so let's look at
the no responses from students
no that's that darker blue color the no
responses for students
is this area right over here
and then the no so i can maybe i'll
shade all of that in
and then the no responses from staff
and parents combined that is
this area right over here and it does
look like indeed the total no responses
from students this area is much larger
than this area right over here so i like
this choice
as well